the grupo especial di operationes
known as hale are the special operation
forces of the spanish national police
corps
the heyo has rapid response capabilities
and is responsible for vip protection
duties
as well as countering and responding to
terrorism
with the growing threat of terrorism and
several organized crime groups from
within spain
the spanish military staff announced the
requirement for a more specialized unit
in november
1977. the hair was formed
a group who'd spent some time with the
german gsg9 were tasked with the
training of the new unit
and in march 1978 the first courses
began
the first access course ended on the
19th of january 1979.
on the 23rd of february the unit was
officially announced to the public
the hail was organized in much the same
way as other police tactical units
throughout europe
their main focus is dealing with
terrorist attacks including aircraft
hijackings
maritime threats and hostage taking but
they are also active
in protecting visiting heads of state
and providing security for high-profile
events
hopeful candidates require a minimum of
two years experience in the national
police corps
and must have experience in either
martial arts scuba diving
marksmanship or explosives once accepted
they are run through the access trial
which contains both physical and
psychological tests checking strength
and durability
as well as the mental capabilities of
each candidate
if successful potential members are put
through a specialization course
candidates are required to master
instrumental juridical
socio-professional and police sciences
and techniques
the success rate of joining heyo is
approximately three percent of
candidates
every year after the reactivation of
team rambo in 2015
two heyo operators were recruited to
bring their skills and expertise
to assist in the fight against terrorism
on a global scale
these operators were named jackal and
[Music]
mira
[Music]
codenamed jekyll is an attacking
operator in team rainbow
born in seyuta a spanish city on the
north coast of africa
bordered by morocco it lies along the
boundary between the mediterranean sea
and the atlantic ocean although very
little is known about his parents and in
what circumstances led them to
disappearing from his life
his last names identified that his
father was most likely spanish
and his mother moroccan so he spent the
majority of his younger years as a
foster child
residing in a large residential
institution with many many other
children
with very little affection and scarcely
any adequate adult guidance
the systems in place at this time were
poor at best
and many children were housed in numbers
far greater than what these institutions
could hold
eventually over time the system expanded
to include foster homes
but these were few and far between and
no home was ever permanent for long
amelia means to time over until he was
old enough to no longer be the states
concerned
had it not been for his older brother
faisal who became his legal guardian
when he was old enough
he would have spent his entire childhood
within the foster care system
from there the brothers seemed to
disappear and it was not until some
years had passed
that they were located again in ao
principe alfonso
a working class neighborhood in the
south of the spanish city of seyuda
in north west africa discovered in an
abandoned building
lying critically injured next to his
brother's lifeless body
although the neighborhood had become the
center of drug trading in recent years
with no clear motives no witnesses and
no murder weapon
the local authorities determined the
case inconclusive and just another
result of street violence
with his brother murdered jack was once
again without a home
one of the police officers was
compassionate towards him and took him
under his wing
to help guide jackal through this
difficult time in his life
after that night jackal was determined
to unravel the events that had led to
the loss of his brother the murder had
not been found
the case was still open and he made it
his goal in life to join the national
police corps the day he turned 18.
jackal was fast-tracked through the
academy with the assistance of the
officer who'd been helping him
he quickly passed all mandatory
qualifications and he stood out among
the rest
he was a fast learner with exceptional
lateral thinking
his dedication and determination
resulted in the closure of a number of
criminal investigations
but unfortunately his brothers wasn't
among them
the killing of his brother is always on
his mind and as more and more time
passes
his frustration only grows as the
likelihood of ever being sold
only becomes further more improbable
although jackal would never admit to it
he clearly holds onto extreme guilt
regarding what happened to his brother
and what's more this only got worse
because he eventually left his job as a
criminal investigator
maybe this is why he always says before
an operation that it won't let this one
slip away
eventually jackal was flagged by heyo
for further training
as a member of the unit he learned how
to cultivate a number of his skills in
the field
and he excelled in off-road driving
abseiling marksmanship
and knowledge of terrorist groups
ever since he can remember jekyll has
been a very competitive individual
as a foster child his future was always
uncertain and his early life was usually
chaotic and unpredictable
at a very young age he needed to learn
how to protect and fend for himself and
often worried incessantly about his
basic needs being met
because of this it created the need for
him to control his environment
and with this also came a problem with
sleeping
a person who didn't grow up in foster
care may remember the feeling of
sleeping at a friend's house or in a
relative's home
and not sleeping well in those places
because they're filled with unfamiliar
sights and sounds
so unsurprisingly even when a foster
child is placed in a home with kind and
loving foster parents
the strange new surroundings can be
difficult to overcome especially if they
change homes frequently
paired with this overwhelming sense of
responsibility surrounding his brother's
death
and what may have initially started as
guilt has since turned into full-blown
insomnia
however given the nature of his career
and that he's always expected to be
alert and ready to go
this could be seen as an advantage this
is also a result of one of his learned
behaviors
as a foster child he always felt the
need to be alert and watching out for
himself
and his brain is constantly in a state
of hyper-vigilance unable to fully relax
the consequences of deep unresolved
issues from his childhood
continue to plague him even to this day
and are naturally concerned for his
mental well-being
and whether he is living his life for
himself or just purely out of guilt
however jackal has recently been taking
steps in the right direction
he has started guest lecturing and even
teaching part-time at the national
police corps academy
he also volunteers with at-risk youth
where he is able to share his
experiences
and provide stability to their lives
this work is more than just helping
others
it provides him with the purpose and
connections with people he didn't know
he was missing
the past experiences of jackal have
resulted in an operative
with a very protective nature and an
almost manic intense desire for ultimate
justice
he's extremely competitive and has been
heard saying before etop that he's able
to flip a mental switch inside of him
allowing him unwavered focus on his
abilities
jekyll has solid relationships with many
of his teammates including specialist
thatcher
twitch and lion but also of course
fellow halo specialist
mira of which they both have immense
respect for one another
he pays homage to his ancestry on his
mother's side as he often quotes a line
from the famous arab poet
al-mutunabi where he recites the steed
the knight and the desert all know me
now you will too
like the jackal he was named after he
tracks and hunts down his prey
and exacts his vengeance upon them
jekyll's gadget is the inox model 3
inspired by the fbi's quick capture
platform
the inops was created as a mobile
tracking device that is able to identify
and follow a person's footsteps in real
time
originally this forensic tool was used
to track terrorist cells back to their
hidden compounds
in the mountains of afghanistan
[Music]
codenamed mira is a defending operator
in team rainbow
meera grew up in madrid spain although
she had a sister for as far back as she
can remember
it had always been just her and her
father
mira and her sister were polar opposites
growing up
an example of this is when they were
young they were each given a doll
while her sister did the usual thing of
dressing it up and having tea parties
mira cut her doll open to see how it
worked
she would work alongside her father in
his auto repair shop
often helping out with incredibly
complex repairs and she gained an
invaluable understanding of the
intricate workings of machines
her father never spoke of her mother so
mira never knew who she was
or what had happened in order for her
mother to leave them
however he did share a lot of special
memories of his own mother
so unsurprisingly over time her
grandmother's morals and strength
instilled important values in mirror
and she too became a significant role
model in her life
her grandmother fought in spanish civil
war where women for the first time would
be involved in large numbers
in combat and in support roles on the
front line
the bond between father and daughter was
incredibly strong and one night this was
only further solidified
she was only seven years old when her
father became pinned underneath one of
the cars he was working on
trapped and unable to move he calmly
instructed his daughter to leave him
and go get help but she was fearful what
if she left him and he died
what if she couldn't find help in time
it was just the two of them and she
needed to save him
she grabbed the heavy jack and despite
his protests and how much she struggled
in the beginning
she eventually managed to free him from
underneath the car only then did she run
for help
mira is an individual who is ferociously
protective especially when it comes to
the ones closest to her
she strives to be a hero not because
she's after the glory and notoriety
but because someone has to step up to
the plate and she's always felt that
it's her place to do so
her talent lies in her mechanically
minded way of thinking which was only
further cultivated with the help of her
father
he allowed her to push herself under his
gentle guidance encouraging her to work
things out for herself
yet was close enough to advise her if
she needed it
later on mira went on to study
mechanical engineering and metallurgy
which is the study of the physical and
chemical behavior of metallic elements
being surrounded by machinery reminds
her of her father and helps to solidify
his memory after his passing
yet she also wanted to do more with her
talents so she looked for an opportunity
to help others
her values had instilled her with a
strong sense of justice and an
obligation to serve
so she went on to join the national
police corps
working with them highlighted what she
believed was a need for better equipment
and because of her efforts a number of
new bulletproof materials were developed
which went on to help protect her
teammates during ops
encouraged by her superiors to apply for
heyo she comfortably secured a position
within the unit
beating more than 100 other applicants
harry quickly became aware of mira and
all of her talents
he saw her as a vital piece in rainbow's
future in moving forward
so he offered her the position as
director of research and development
not long after taking this role she was
also added to the combat roster
this enabled her to further test her
inventions along with enabling her to
develop and improve herself under field
conditions
harry believes that mira is his keystone
and without her he would be lost
mira is an operator who was loyal and
stubborn and fiercely protective
her kind heart and concerns for others
is highly valued by her colleagues
and she naturally dominates a leadership
role during operations
in a way that is not forceful or
domineering and others generally fall in
line as the result she enjoys her time
working in the lab
and it has allowed her to advance her
skills immensely
as she once told harry with just a whiff
of machine oil i am transported back in
time
i see him my father hunched over a car
engine
looking up at me smiling
the armor she wears is her own
reinforced design and she is also
responsible for inventing knox hell
device
she was the lead engineer in creating
the specialized ballistic shield for
tachanka's lmg
and working alongside twitch the
creation of the cce shield for clash
also it was her thinker and iq who
together collaborated to refine warden's
smart glasses
however she doesn't get along with every
operator her
and specialist ash seem to have an
ongoing rivalry
both are solid leaders and incredibly
strong world individuals
though they approach challenges in
completely different ways
in her spare time she enjoys creating
sculptures made out of used machine
parts and ballistic glass the intricate
designs are bold and enchanting
and are a great source of pride for her
mira thinks on her feet she's adaptable
and versatile
which makes her incredibly difficult to
predict and she delights in taking risks
her creativity and unpredictability
gives her the unparalleled ability to
dominate even the smallest of urban
environments
above everyone else if her and ash just
learned how to combine the unique
strengths together
they would undoubtedly see the value in
each other's approaches
mira came up with the idea for the black
mirror during operation
blue orion where she was forced to
improvise a panic room at the embassy of
spain
in tel aviv this experience helped her
design a specialized laminated glass
which when deployed can produce a
one-way mirror on any wall
however if the air pressure is disrupted
the glass is ejected
creating an opening and leaving members
on either side vulnerable
from here i'm hoping to cover some of
the new night having operators
and give a bit of an update to
everyone's maybe
not so favorite pmc that was more
recently added to the rainbow roster
i must admit i wasn't a huge fan of them
adding the pmc to the story
but the law behind them is quickly
becoming one of the more interesting
across the operators
anyway thank you very much for watching
i hope you've enjoyed it and i'll catch
you in the next one
cheers
you